okay welcome everybody and welcome to everyone
tuning online thanks for coming it's our pleasure
today to have no back College visiting from epfl
in Switzerland novaks uh just about to finish his
PhD he's working with Arjen Lenstra there and
at the moment he's interning with our friends
from across the lake at Amazon about to finish
the internship there and then go back and finish
up on his PhD it's great to have another today
to talk about uh to talk about Swag channels
particularly because Psych is our remaining
candidate in the East standardization process
and uh this is really important work that's very
topical right now to um yeah see how to attack
and defend the slice game so pass it over to
nodo thank you Craig for the kind introduction
so today I'll be presenting psych channels zero
value side Channel attacks on psych so this is
a paper that I worked on in collaboration
with other people with Luca defeo emerging
and we will present it later
this year at chess in September
um so I'll be talking about side channels and
I'll be talking about Psych and how to attack a
psych how to attack psych with the power analysis
side channels so if you know about psych I guess
most other people on The Talk No it's uh one of
the post Quantum key encapsulation mechanisms it
is uh currently fighting to be standardized so a
couple of days ago or a couple of weeks ago nist
uh chose uh one uh algorithm to be standardized
which is kyber but uh Psych is still alive it's
in the fourth round and uh you know now is the
time of analysis of side channels and uh we have
shown some some weaknesses how to patch them and
hopefully you know it'll go it'll go further uh
through the next round or to being standardized uh
psych means super singular exogenic encapsulation
so essentially what what it does it computes
isogenes between super singular elliptic curves
uh if you don't know what exogenes are that's not
too important I'm not going to discuss exogenous
and in the first part of my talk uh but it
is essentially similar to elliptic curves
and similar to diffie-hellman and uh for
the attack that I'm going to present today
it's essentially same as elliptic curved with some
differences that I'm gonna explain towards the end
so uh elliptic curves what are elliptic curves
these are geometric objects that are also groups
so a geometric object it means that elliptic curve
is a Formula it is a a function X and Y which
you can write like this in particular uh we use
elliptic curves which are of the type y squared
equals X cubed plus a squared plus X and a is a
variable which defines the curve so for example
in psyc when a is equal to 6 you get one of the
curves which is used in psyc one one of many
um a point on elliptic curve is simply a pair
of coordinates X and Y which lies on the curve
so X and Y which satisfy the formula in this
case the point minus 1 2 if you plug it in
it will satisfy the above formula so -1 2 is the
point on the curve e0 but we will also be working
with General curves with General A's um elliptic
curves are groups what that means is that if you
have two points you can add them so there is some
operation like like in the natural numbers if you
have two numbers you can add them well if you have
two points on a curve you can add them and you can
also compute the negative of a point uh how do
you do that well there's a geometric way to do
that like if you have a point B and a point Q you
draw a line then you draw a vertical line and the
last point of intersection is point P plus Q uh
there's also an algebraic way to do it for given
a formula and we're gonna show that formula in
the last slide now if you can add points you can
also do other things with points like you can
compute multiples of a point by adding a point
to itself M times this is how you get M times p
and these are uh the main objects the main parts
uh of site that that will use today so how do you
compute these elliptic curve group operations so
if you have two points p and Q represented with
their coordinates X and Y we want to compute P
plus Q Where um what psyc does is it is smart it
doesn't do it in the standard way but instead it
it tries to save up on Space uh by representing
these points with only their x coordinates so p
and Q are represented only with their X and the
Y's drop however if you do that directly then you
lose some information when dropping the Y so in
order to be able to to add these two points from
only their x coordinate we also need to add
a third point which is Q minus p and now if
we have the x coordinate of P the x coordinate
of Q and the x coordinate of Q minus B then we
can add B and Q by Simply Computing this value so
we compute one multiplication one subtraction a
square another subtraction another Square another
multiplication and then we divide these two values
except that we don't actually do that the
reason we don't do that is because divisions
are expensive so if you want to divide it's
going to cost you a lot and you're going to
have an inefficient algorithm and they're also
going to be other security related problems
um so instead of computing divisions uh what is
done in psyc but also what is done in general
in elliptic curve cryptography is that points are
represented as in a slightly different way we use
projective coordinates so um a number of value
X XP is presented as a pair of values x and z
and what is particular is that this pair of values
they're quotient is equal to XP so you can think
of natural numbers representing them as rational
numbers so 2 is equal to 2 divided by 1 or 4
divided by 2. so you you save the numerator
and the denominator of a number separately
and this is called a projective coordinates and
what's nice about projective coordinates is that
you can compute things without dividing you
can multiply two numbers by Computing two
multiplications you can add two numbers by
Computing a couple of multiplications and
additions but you can compute any version
without Computing anything you just swap
the numerator and the denominator and you have the
inverse of a projected value so what's good about
projective coordinates is that you don't need
to divide and you can speed up your algorithm
um so what happens in Psych what
happens is that this formula
of adding two elliptic curve points becomes
this formula so there is an overhead instead of
representing three points with three coordinates
we now represent them with six coordinates
but uh when you compute the addition you just
compute this value and then the numerator and
the denominator separately and you save them
separately so you can speed up the algor
um now this is uh one property of
projective coordinates but it's not
the main one that I'll be discussing
about today uh what is more important
with respect to projective coordinates is that
they allow some level they give some level of
provide some level of Defense from side Channel
attacks you can think about the following so
let's say you have some value which is a a
public value a number which is loaded into
a computer which is under attack so it is being
attacked a power analysis is done on this computer
uh so this value is going to be loaded stored
it's going to go through the pipeline it's going
to be operated on and when it is being operated
on some power is being consumed and uh the power
consumption is proportional to the hemming weight
of the number which is being operated on to put
it in simple terms so this is a threat model
which is valid in most of the processors today
um and and this creates a problem this creates a a
way to attack protocols um why well because if we
have public data in the pipeline and this data is
operated on depending on some secret for example
one secret bit and this is what is done in psyc
you have one secret bit you use it to change some
data which is public then we can simply make
a guess on how that data will update and then
we can do power analysis to see if our guess
was correct like if the the power consumption
was what we would expect it to be if some gas
value would have passed through the pipeline
um so what we want to do we want to defend from
this and we want that uh values which are being
saved in memory uh we don't want them to be
known we want to hide them that is we want to
randomize them and this is what coordinate for
uh for coordinate projective coordinates allow
so um one projected coordinate represented with
a numerator and a denominator is not unique it
can be represented in many different ways in
particular so XZ can be also saved as Lambda
X Lambda Z for any non-zero lamp why well
because the quotient is always the same x
divided by Z is equal to Lambda x divided
by Lambda Z simple example um number three
you can save it in memory as a pair three one or
you can save this memory as a pair minus 39 13.
um and what what's good about this is that um you
can essentially make sure that the numbers which
are stored in your computer are completely random
so uh in in the beginning what psych did was it
loaded a point represented as X and it stored it
in memory as little X and one so X was represented
as x divided by one in other words the capital
x was Little X and the capital Z was just one
and this was or proposed to be patched by
randomizing the coordinates what does that
mean that means you choose a random number and
then you multiply both of the numerator and the
denominator by this random number and what happens
now is that when this number is saved in memory
it is completely random and when this number
is saved in memory it is also completely Rand
so once they enter the pipeline and start being
operated on the the power consumption done
um when Computing these numbers is
is random like you cannot you lose
this correlation between the power
consumption and the values themselves
and this is true so this number is completely
random in all cases except for one and that case
is the case when a coordinate is equal to zero
and this is where the zero values comes from in
the title of our presentation and so if a number
is zero you multiply by random value you're gonna
get zero again and this was uh what we try to
exploit and we formalized our attack in the
following manner so we want to force a Target
party which is Computing side we wanted to we
want to force it to compute some point which has
one of the coordinates equal to zero because then
we know how that will reflect to power consumption
and if we have access to power measurement we can
we can gather that information um there are
two points two such points in in Psych there
is the point one zero and the point zero one
so the first point is known as the appointed
Infinity on elliptic curves and the second point
is particular to psych it's a it's a special point
um okay so let me explain psych finally
what psych does a typical execution of Psych
takes his input a triple of x coordinates
of points p q and P minus Q uh as explained
previously and then a secret which is a
secret number which is a random natural number
the party which computes psych does that in
the three following step first there is the
initialization step where these three
are fine coordinates are turned into
three elliptic coins uh in in projected form and
they are we can assume that they are randomized
then these three projective points are funneled to
a three-point ladder which is uh something similar
to scalar multiplication on regular elliptic
curves and we use them to compute a new elliptic
curve point at the point P plus s k times Q this
new point is called R and then in the third step
of psyc the point R is used to compute a secret
exogeny so starting from the starting curve the
target computes an exogeny to another curve and
this final curve is a secret a common Secret
so today I will only cover the attack on the
three-point ladder however in our work we also
did an attack on the Exogen computation and I
have some extra slides for that so maybe after
we talk I can I can get it from a little
more details on these argument computation
um so the three-point ladder is um as I said it
is essentially scalar multiplication on elliptic
curves it works in the following way so you take
three points you're saying you assign them to new
three variables r0 is Q R1 is PR2 is Q minus p and
then you go through all the bits of the secret key
and you do the following so if the secret bit is
zero if the secret bit is one you will add r0 to
R1 if the secret bit is zero you will throw it
away and by throw it away I mean you will add it
to the second variable which is kind of a dummy
variable um and then at every step you double r0
and if you think about it what happens is
you take Q you double it at every step and
then whenever secret bit is one you add it to
p and it's not so difficult to see that the
final outcome uh this point P will be updated
to the point P plus skq which is exactly the
secret point which we're looking for so the
question which we posed ourselves was okay
um what happens during this Loop and how can
we make sure that one of these three points
for example the point R2 is he has one of the
coordinates equal to zero um during the execution
so what happens at step k would be the the main
question if we posed also um so our attack works
in the following way so we extract secret bits
from the target party one by one so first we
attack the bottom most bit then the first bit
then the second bit and so on and uh what we
always do is that we assume that we have all K
minus one bits in order to be able to attack bit
K and to extract so we let's start by assuming
that we have like the first K minus one bits of
the secret key which are represented like this if
we know this value then there are only two options
um in the three-point letter at step K and
these two options depend only on the Kate bit
and if you develop the formula from previous slide
you will see that the third bit is either going to
be equal the third point is zero going to be equal
to this value which depends only on some known
information or it is going to be equal to this
value if the secret key bit is one which also can
be pre-computed right if we have PQ and we have
the secret key the known part of the sequence
um and this later leads us to the
attack so the attack works as follows
I want to extract sacred bit K I assume
that I know all the previous secret bits
when we compute the public key a
maliciously generated public key
it's made out of three points QP and Q minus B so
I select Q to be a random point on a random curve
I select B to be equal to this value over here and
Q minus p is the difference of those two points
Compares them compress them into a public key
and send them to the Target now the target starts
Computing the three-point letter and at step K the
following thing happens so the third variable R2
is going to be equal to the point T which was
the point zero one or zero something random
if there was an organization if the secret key
bit as step K is 0 or it is going to be equal to
something completely random and non-zero I can
assure you of that if the secret key bit is one
so in other words we get a zero
coordinate or a zero point if and only if
a bit of the secret key is equal to zero so
what do we do then will we do parallels we
measure the power consumption of the computer
we zoom in at the Kate step of the loop and
then we see what happens and then we make a
guess was this zero or was this not a zero
and if we make a correct guess we repeat we go
to the next bit how does this look in practice
it looks like this so it's actually not
power analysis this is electromagnetic
signal analysis so it's it's done even without
touching the the wires or the the processor
um so it is a bit weaker but it is strong enough
so this is how the computation of the three-point
letter looks these are the first 20-ish steps of
the loop and this is the case where uh the value
is not zero this on the other hand is the case
where you get the value 0 at step 12 if I remember
correct so if you count these spikes somewhere
around here is 12 step 12 of The Loop and you can
see that the power consumption suddenly becomes
kind of atypical because you have all zeros
um now maybe somebody's watching this
presentation from their phone and they
say oh but I I don't really see the difference
looks pretty pretty equal to me so I'm gonna
say okay don't worry that's not all there's
actually more to it there is another point
with zeros uh and this is the point zero zero
and uh let me show you how to compute this point
so if you remember the formula for Point
Edition it looks a bit something like this
and adding two points it depends on three it has
three inputs b q and P minus Q or Q minus p well
when the point Q minus p is equal to the point
T which is the point zero one or zero something
then if you Analyze This formula correctly you
will see that the point P plus Q will always
be equal to zero zero right so and how does this
relate to the previous attack well in the previous
attack we showed that if the secret key bit is
zero then the third Point R2 is equal to the point
t to the point zero something and the point R2 it
it's kind of it's a q minus P it is r0 minus R1
so what happens is that the point r0 plus R1
which is uh uh being updated in the loop becomes
0 0. and uh one might think okay this is nice so
instead of one zeros I'm gonna get three zeros so
this uh that that graph that I showed before it's
it's gonna have like spikes three times as large
not really actually there's there's much more
than that so the point zero zero is it's kind
of special it's not a projective point if you did
projective geometry you will say oh but there's
not even a point this is zero divided by zero it
doesn't mean anything well not only that it does
mean anything but it has a very nice property uh
if you have this point as an input it's always
going to be an output so whenever you compute
something if 0 0 is one of the inputs you can
have multiple inputs it's the output is going to
be zero zero and this is nice because it leads to
an avalanche effect if you compute zero zero one
time then every other variable from that point on
written in your memory saved in your computer
going through the pipeline is going to be zero
so until the end of the computation of Psych
you're only going to have zeros and this is pretty
easy to exploit using side channel so if you think
about it you have to distinguish two cases run an
algorithm everything in memory is zero or run the
same algorithm but the values in memory are random
and if you have access to power consumption this
becomes pretty easy to distinguish so somebody
might have noticed that on the previous slide
I have cropped this picture because we never
did an attack by only looking for one zero
we were looking for this Avalanche of zeros
and over here we had the first zero happening so
that point T the point zero something was computed
here and it led to an avalanche and then from
this point onwards you can clearly distinguish
the power consumption uh between uh having all
zeros in memory which is shown on the bottom slide
or having random values in memory which is shown
in the top it's just a single tricks this is just
a single trace yeah this is a single Trade Center
and this is only 20 steps of the Dublin ad of the
three-point ladder Loop this Loop goes on for
about 250 steps so you can think that this
continues for a long time and it doesn't finish
there because the three-point letter is the first
part of Psych this is about 20 of the runtime
later you have another eighty percent of the
run time when a similar uh thing continues so it
becomes awfully easy to notice with side channels
um and um of course a natural question to ask is
okay how do we how do we defend from that uh well
the the one way to defend which is pretty easy uh
if if you look at it closely you'll see that the
problem or one of the problem is that the points
that are generated are generated maliciously they
don't satisfy among the other things they don't
satisfy an order formula or Independence I didn't
explain what Independence was but you can think
like they're a thing corrector so if you check
that their of correct order and that the input the
three input points are independent and this is not
difficult to check then we have shown in our paper
that you will never get a single zero throughout
the whole computational cycle so it's a good way
to defend from the whole attack however there is a
problem with this counter measurement I mean the
problem is the cost it's around 10 percent and
psych well I didn't mention this in the beginning
but psych has a some drawbacks is that it is the
slowest of of all post Quantum algorithms but it
also has the smallest keys but it is slow so this
additional overhead uh is is just you know it's
a bigger problem than than it would be for some
other algorithms uh now before I finish I wanted
to mention three uh more things the first thing
is uh how does say compare to ecdh this is my
point of view like why why this attack happens
um well easy the age first of all elliptic
curve difficult man it has only one curve
so an elliptic curve difficult you don't get
to choose a curve you get one curve this curve
is hard coded into the algorithm it's not that
somebody gives you the coordinates of the curve
no it's saved in memory already and you cannot
mess with it in Psych there are many Curves in
in a in an honest execution of Psych you expect
to get some random curve right and that just
means there's a bigger surface of attack another
problem is that the Curves in elliptic curved if
you heldman they're fixed but they have an order
which is let me call it nice so the order is a
large prime number or at most a small multiple of
a large prime number I don't know a single curve
which doesn't which is used in crypto and does
not have one of these three orders so Q4 Q or 8 Q
on the other hand it's Psych the order is
highly factorizable so it's a it's a multiple
of a large part of two and a large power of
three and uh this is if you're being honest
however psych doesn't check the order of the
curve when you receive it as an input so if
you're malicious you could take a curve of a
different order and there are many curves so
who knows what other malicious things you could
do third thing let the curved diffie-hellman
uses only 1.4 input so if you remember
diffie-hellman I send you G you compute G
to DX or I send you an elliptic curve point you
compute x times that lift the curve Point well
for psych it's not the same for site you get
three points and you need to set at least two
so this also becomes a problem this is actually
the reason why we cannot like we couldn't do
this attack that I just presented in ecdh uh among
other reasons because there's only one input point
um and this input Point not only there's only
one of it it has a a small number of orders that
you can choose from like if it's on the curve
then it has one of these four orders because Q
is a large Prime so you don't really divide Q by
much by something other than Q itself and what in
psyc uh we we get the the previous problem again
since the order is so highly factorizable you can
get points uh of many different orders so this
would be something like 250 times 150 different
possibilities for orders four points on psych
and again if you're being honest with the Curve
um and finally in ecdh if you want to check
that the point is a correct order that's easy
you can do it in a negligible time
but in Psych this this cause uh well actually I
I just noticed that this this was wrong what I've
written in this slide I wrote that uh the check
that the points are honestly generated is costly
no the the check that the points are of correct
order is costly and it is around 10 percent of
runtime but you don't get honesty you you don't
get the proof that they're honestly generated they
could be of the correct order but there could be
something else malicious done on them and as far
as I know and I believe that it's probably very
it's very hard to prove that points are honestly
generated probably as hard as breaking Psych
um okay um so second thing before I wrap up I
mentioned that we did two attacks one attacks on
the three-point ladder and another attack on the
exogeny and both attacks are similar in that
we force this Avalanche of the uh effect so we
we for the computation of a point zero zero and
then there's effect however I believe that there
are some deep differences in how these two things
happen in the two cases in the three-point letter
the problem is that the formula is not complete
and I guess some people know what that means I'm
not going to get into explaining that this is
on one side it's unavoidable on elliptic curves
on the other side it can be avoided and and
again I and and this makes sense what I just said
um and and so if you think about it we complete
we computed something which makes sense we added
two elliptic curve points it was the formula
that was the problem the formula at these two
points it gives you zero zero and actually if you
go deeper into it those two zeros they cancel out
in a smart way and you can get something which
is Meaningful in the second attack the exogeny
attack uh the problem is deeper we we force the
target to compute something completely nonsensical
and and it computes things which don't make sense
like points which are not on the elliptic curve
isogenes which have bad kernel things which are
not algebraic and then it just messes up so much
that you get a zero zero in the end so I think
you know if you think about this that there is
uh more to be analyzed in the exogeny and there
are some additional threats coming from there
um and now to end I I just wanted to explain
how the hertzbleed attack works so a couple
of weeks ago this new attack on info processor was
published this this was not done by me so this was
done by a different team but they used the same
exact attack that I just showed you as a proof of
concept for an attack for a timing attack on x86
processors so I presented a power analysis stack
and they showed they exploited the weakness of
a x86 to translate this attack to timing attack
uh so how is this done well essentially um they
target um processors x86 processors with turbo
boost and turbo boost is important here turbo
boost and dynamic voltage and frequency scaling
so what is dvfs essentially you can think about
it this way you have a processor at clocks at four
gigahertz and then you turn on dvfs and dvfs says
okay I'm going to allow you to work between three
gigahertz and five gigahertz because I'm good
and of course you say well I mean that's great
I'm just gonna start bumping at five gigahertz
because I I want to be faster you know I want to
do more and it starts Computing a lot faster but
there can be problems with that for example you
can start running out of battery because if you
compute faster you use more energy or you could
start overheating and so if you start overheating
the controller steps in and says oh wait the
CPU temperature is too high you cannot continue
Computing at five gigahertz because you're gonna
you're gonna burn so let me lower the frequency
to three gigahertz so that it cools down and then
I can let you compute fast later again and this I
think in essence can be captured in two formulas
first one is that the power is proportional
to the voltage squared times frequency
and the second formula is that the voltage
is proportional to the Hemingway are of the
machine words in memory or to the this hemming
distance between consecutive machine words or
you can think about it to the number of bits
that are flipped when you come when you flip
bits you need to use an energy to flip a bit
or write a zero so it's proportional to be
and so uh essentially works in the following way
suppose you have a lot of bits to flip right well
you flip more bits you need more current well
if you need more current you increase the power
and if you increase the power the temperature of
the CPU increases but if the temperature increases
then the controller steps in and says okay
you're overheating I need to lower the frequency
but if you lower the frequency you increase the
run time because that is what frequency means
and therefore you can uh extend this attack really
easily so if you remember the the attack from a
couple of sides before if your secret key bit is
zero then you compute the projected point zero
zero but if you compute the projected point
zero zero you get the Avalanche effect what
does that mean all the variables are zero all the
variables are zero you never flip a single bit so
you use less current and you can obtain a faster
runtime the other hand if a secret key bit is one
then all the variables are you you don't get a
zero zero you get random and all the valuables
are random and all the Heming weights are random
and you flip bits and you use more current and
you get a slower runtime and this difference in
runtimes it's it's not Stark it's not like you
get a second more but you can definitely notice
it uh if you run the attack enough time so this
is from the hertzblade paper and this is a
histogram of the runtimes for the two cases
uh when a secret key bit is equal to one another
secret to get bit secret key bit is equal to zero
so yeah sometimes one can be faster than the other
but on average if you have zero more zeros you're
gonna be faster and this simply shows how to
extend a par analysis deck to timing attack
and therefore to a long distance attack and so
on but also as I said before you do the point
order check and you fix it and uh and this
covers my talk thank you for your attention
we see some things clapping up on the thing just
thank you thanks thanks very much
um we might have time for the isogeny party if you
if you're happy to do that but I'll ask if anyone
wants to ask questions at this point if that's
all right yes so yeah any any questions from well
from the audience here or from the audience online
you can either you can either type them into the
chat and I'll relay them or I can uh or you can
unmute and ask your question directly if you like
any any questions out there check the picture
touch bathroom floors great okay so I've only got
one question at this point um the performance of
using Montgomery is basically identical to
using Edwards roughly speaking okay just do it
so I think that the points of small order on
Edwards on the Edwards curve if it's defining
the right way don't have any zero values yeah
I mean that's what Edwards Edwards Corners do
you kind of make the the the formula complete by
moving them in an extension yeah that wasn't even
buried off in the extension field so it would not
be was just reach the whole Library Avenue Edwards
uh well I guess you could offend defend from the
three-point ladder but I don't think you could
defend from the exogeny attack and also I don't
know how these formulas look on these objects yeah
because right because you fixed the the
um the problem of formulas being complete
that's not the only problem so this is just like
you this only fixes the addition formula which is
complete right the isogeny can also output a zero
zero and I don't know yeah exactly so I'm not sure
uh I don't even know how exogenic formulas look
on Android skirt would there be as additions
and I'm also not sure that when it when a
curve has such a smooth order like that if
if you still get to vary the points yeah
that's kind of odd because this is like
kind of important at that point
I I you know you use these
um yeah I don't know if you could throw
it out at an extension field because
um because you use points that are about it
so so it definitely cannot be in an extension
field but maybe you know maybe it's something
cool um usually I'd say thanks again and wrap
up but I'm I'm trying to hear the the other
slides if you're happy yeah I will I will if I was
online we might we're going to continue with the
um the auxiliary part of the talk which is
to hear more about the isogony attacks right
yeah people carry on since we've got time
that would be great if you don't mind okay
uh oh yeah so these are the people from the
cards newspaper just want to give them credit
support their work um so let me jump over this uh
outliner the isogeny attack so the idea is that
I want to force the kernel generating point
of the exogeny to have order a power of two
when you compare the three eyes actually
so you can also attack the two eyesogeny
with a power of three point or any L
isogeny with an L Prime order point
um and and we showed that there is a a
special number called the breaking point
such that if the order of this point is 2 to the
r well when R is smaller than the breaking point
then you always get zero value and Avalanche if
the order of the point is to the to the r with
r greater than the breaking point then you
get no zero values and everything is right
and this you can do in two steps so I'll show
first how to how to force the order to be the
way we want it so we can we can force the order of
uh the chronological point to be 2 to the r plus
minus one plus one or plus zero essentially
depending on the secret key bit so either 2
to the r or two to the r minus 1 for any R and
and in particular we're going to use 2 to the
o or two to the O minus one to always fall into
one of these two cases depending on the secret
and once you have that will show what what happens
if R is of this bad order how and why do you get
all those zeros order forcing is a it's very
simple but the formulas look large essentially
you you take a point of order 2
to the r minus 1. and uh and then
you kind of want that to be p and then
you take Q to be an independent point
of order 2 to the r plus K where K is
the bit that you want to expect a compute
and then you update B by subtracting the known
secret key part of Q because you you want to get
rid of this you go one to start from Bitcoin
right and so when you compute P plus skq now
well p is the point of order 2 to the r minus one
line is this the Q and Q you just develop uh SK
um the whole SK so this is the known
part and this is starting from the K
bits upwards and of course these two cancel
out so the minus known part in the known part
and you're left with the S point of order 2
to the r minus 1. 2 to the K times Q which
this kind of K cancels out so you
get a point of order 2 to the r
and then another like the remainder which is
a point of order 2 to the r minus 1 or smaller
because this would be like 2 to the K plus 1
times Q so you lose K plus 1 in the exponent
of the order right so this you can kind of ignore
and you get either s which is a point of two to
the r minus 1. plus a point of order 2 to the r
if the secret key bit is one so you get a point
four or two to the r right or if this is zero
you get a point of order 2 to the r minus one
and then another point that which is independent
from it too so they really can't cancel out you
know you don't care and and therefore we you
can control you can do the trick you know if
you know the previous bits based on this next
bit you can control the order of the kernel
point it's either 2 to the r minus one or two
TR and this is for every R almost every r i
mean maybe not when R is higher than what is
the size of the curve something like that but
almost all ours okay and um and that was simple
but what happens during Exogen computation
so isogeny it would uh works as follows so let's
say Bob who's the target computer three to the
i3a zodge and an exogeny is I mean you know
this but I didn't remove it from the slides
it is a hard-coded sequence of the following
operations you do trip links on an elliptic curve
you take a kernel point of order three you
compute the image curve through a three eyesogeny
and then with the same Exogen you can push
some point onto the next curve and another
thing is you can save and load a point these are
the four operations which is which are used in a
subject computation and the order in which you
do them is saved in what is called a strategy
so for example how does it look to compute an
exogeny of degree 3 to the power 7 let's say you
started some curve e0 and you have a some point
R on this curve uh well you take this point and
you start multiplying it with three so you compute
3r 9R 27r so on and so on and so on until you get
to obtain a point of order three which is three
to the 6 times R you use this point as kernel
to compute the next curve and then you start
Computing isogenes to push some saved points
to the next curve then you do the same with the
next Point next curve push points then you do the
save and sometimes you might have to triple it and
so on and so on until you get to the final curve
and you finish your exogenic computation so this
thing can be very nicely represented in a tree
um so what happens if a if a kernel has a
bad order like if this point R is not of the
order three to the seven or three to whatever it
needs to be well you're on the starting curve you
Triple R so even if it's of the band order you're
still gonna triple it and it's gonna work right
and some of these points which are triple they're
going to be saved and this is still okay but then
you start Computing a 3i Dodge and this is the
first problem so your computer three isogeny but
your point is of the bed order what happens well
what happens is that you get something nonsensical
right you're going to get a random curve and
you're going to get random image points the
image points don't have to be on the curve
the curve doesn't have to be exogenous it
doesn't have to be super singular it it
you know it doesn't have to be occur I
mean it's going to be a curve because you get a
coefficient but you know it doesn't make sense
um well they'll and they're going to stay random
until the end of the protocol because like you
then you're not even on elliptic curves you just
compute random stuff with random things right so
you kind of expect to get all random things
until the end uh until the end of Psych you
do except in some cases so there are some things
which are not random and this is kind of expected
it it makes sense like even if an exogeny is a
nonsensical isogeny with a nonsense called kernel
it's going to send the point of infinity to point
Infinity because of the way they are constructed
even if the exogeny is a nonsensical exogeny uh
if the kernel point of the isogeny is equal to
the input point of the exogeny the output point
is going to be the point of infinity which yeah
it kind of makes sense you you want like exogenes
need to have that property for for good kernel
points so uh it happens also if the program points
are bad um and then there's one property which
is Formula related is that if your kernel is the
point in affinity then you get a degenerate curve
the generate curve it means the curve of
coefficients equal 1 divided by zero and
then however you represent that in projective
coordinates they're different representations
um and the final property is that
if you happen to compute a zero
and if you happen to be under the generate
curve and if you just so happen to Triple
that point zero on the generate
curve well you're gonna get zero zero
and this is what we can get so how does that
work well there is a nice if and only if
for getting the zero zero zero zero happens if
and only if one of the two following properties
either two of the points which are saved on The
Starting curve are equal or if two of the points
are different by T probably remember what T was if
they have flipped coordinates but this has also a
deeper algebraic meaning is that one is equal
to the other one plus that point t 0 1 over 2.
so let me just explain the first case but
the other case is essentially identical
what happens if you have two equal points on the
starting curve which are saved well they're going
to be sent to the same points with the Exogen
even though the Exogen is nonsensical it is a
it's a function and a function sends the same
thing to the same thing it's that's what it what
the definition of a function is and since they're
going to preserve this equality eventually one
of them is going to be used to compute an
exogeny as a kernel point the image of one
of it well when you confuse it as a kernel
point then you're going to send the other
point to the pointed Infinity because of
the property mentioned on a previous slide
and that point of infinity is going to be
preserved because you're going to push it
with exogenes to the point Infinity you're going
to triple it to the point of infinity so it's just
going to stay there until eventually you use it
to compute uh an exogeny use it as a kernel so you
compute the exogeny and the image curve is going
to be degenerate but then you're going to also
push that zero to the image curve and eventually
you're going to triple it and eventually you're
going to get that zero zero and I have a very
nice explanation of how that actually looks
so let's start off a point with a point of a
bed order on the curve where we want to compute
an exogeny of the power of three to the power
10. oh so we triple triple triple triple triple
until we get to what we expect to be a point of
order three but is essentially a point of order 2
to the something and let's suppose that these two
large points that the fat ones this one this one
are equal well we use this point to compute an
exogeny and what happens well the next curve is
random not a curve blue means nonsensical so
we push the first point to something Rand we
pushed the large point to something random but
the other large Point goes to the same thing
so fat means equal we push this point to something
random and we continue now again Computing
exogeny random Point random misogyny nonsensical
everything stays Blue but the fat Point stays fat
now compute an exogeny with one of the two equal
points the curve is again something random because
the point is the random itself but the image
of the other point becomes a point at Infinity
represented in light blue and now we continue take
this point Infinity triple it we're on a random
curve so tripling is good I mean you're gonna get
still the point of infinity triple triple triple
oh it's the kernel of exogeny computing exogeny
bam you get a degenerate curve represented as blue
so we continue you approach the random
Point happens to be a random Point
um you push the point in Infinity into the point
of Infinity but now oh excuse me and then you draw
another exogeny and it stays the same because
the exogeny again has zero for a kernel so
the next curve is the generate you push the two
things and finally you need to Triple the point
of infinity at the generate curve what do you get
you get the point zero zero what happens when you
get the point zero zero everything becomes zero
all isogenes all points all curves are zero zero
and this will happen until the end of year
usually this happens like in the first 20
to 30 percent of this graph but uh I can might
even show you later one of the pictures of that
um and and finally how do we get uh
two equal points on the starting curve
um well that's that's pretty simple
because if you think about it what
are the Saved points like they're saved in
the Exogen it's simply some indices I such
that 3 to the I are is saved so like it's
10 points usually or log of e three points
and when are two points equal they're equally
if and only if 3 to the alpha R equals 30 beta r
for some uh Alpha Beta in the index set and
somebody will say yeah plus minus yeah plus minus
let's not be too detailed here um and what what
is this well this is just a a modular equation
because the point R is of some order 2 to the r
then this is just a modular equation modulo to TBR
and uh what happens is that not only is just the
model equations but if you have a solution modulo
2 to the r you will have a solution module 2 to
the r minus 1. because it projects and therefore
if you have the strategy and the strategy is
public you can show that there is this breaking
point you can always find some R which is so large
that for any pair of indices this formula here
becomes non-zero and therefore if it's true for
R it's true for all the exponents larger than r
and you will be able to find some R whether
where this equation is equal to zero so it
will be equal to zero from our onwards down up
to R is equal to zero if you think about it let's
say R is equal to zero what does that mean that
means the point is the point is infinity well
of course it's going to repeat right because
it you triple it into itself so there's always
some solution but the more you go up eventually
you're going to run out of solutions they're like
you can even get a heuristic argument why that
is always going to be the same because you have
a small number of indices but the exponent is
so large so you can you don't expect to get an
equate equality here and also you can like
Factor this out so I don't think maybe you
could do like a very inefficient strategy to to
try to fix this but you can't run away from it
um and this doesn't actually only work as I
said before in the three eyesogen it works
uh on the two Exogen and the three isogeny on
any L isogeny on any curve which has an l and
l Prime is arginine you can do this attack
and in particular these are the exponents
for these uh parameters of Psych and here the
exponent is very low because in this curve
you'll remember like the two isogenes are
actually computed with four eyesogenes but
but on this curve you do Toys R Us in the first
step and later you do the four isogenes and
that we thought it was going to be problematic
but actually it's even easier to attack that
um and and for the end this this is how it
looks uh it's it's not so clear the picture but
um this is uh uh how it looks in practice so this
is a three to the 137 so this is the smallest
parameter set of site we send the point of order
two to the eighth and the point of order two to
the nine would have everything dark blue until
the end so everything would be completely random
a point of order 228 it this point here denoted
with a star you can zoom in enough and this same
point here denoted with a star they happen to be
equal so when this isogen is computed pushes it to
the point of infinity propagates blah blah and
eventually over here if you zoom in enough you
get a small first red exogeny and 0.00 and
then it's going to propagate until the end
and uh and that's it and well since I just
have a couple more slides I can just add it
how we attack this with side channel is that
we just computed two baselines essentially we
gave you something which is always going
to be zero independent of your secret key
and then we give you something which is
never zero independent of your secrets
and then we just correlate this Power Trace with
the power press extracted for each bits and and
what we get when we compute this correlation is
the following so either you get the correlation
of 0.99 were you correct or 0.3 when you're
incorrect so it's pretty it's pretty easy
and uh and that covers the Exogen attack
and my presentation thank you thanks again
quickly to the audience once again in
case any new questions have popped up
the chat you can also unmute again if you
weren't trying to make a question anyone
yeah absolutely thank you okay
if not let's thing go back again